2-mal ...
Wir haben 1 eingesetzt,
dann steht da ...
Hier steht 1 plus ...
X Quadrat ist ja 1,
Cosinus von Pi y ist ...
Cosinus von Pi ...
Der Cosinus ist bei 2 Pi gleich 1,
d.h. bei Pi meines Erachtens 0.
Nein, dann ist er minus 1.
Richtig, minus 1.
Maximilian Janisch ist 11 Jahre alt
und löst mit seinem Vater - einem
Mathematikprofessor im Ruhestand -
mathematische Aufgaben
auf Universitätsniveau.
Wir sind hier gerade
beim Differenzieren
mehrdimensionaler Funktion,
meistens 2-dimensionaler.
Auf welcher Stufe
wird das unterrichtet?
Ja, das ist meines Erachtens
2. Semester oder 3. Semester ...
2. Semester, und zwar ist das
die Abschlussprüfung
des 2. Semesters von ...
... von 2014.
2014, die letzte Abschlussprüfung.
Und das ist kein Problem für dich?
Diese hier gerade nicht,
aber die von De Lellis schon.
Da fühlen wir uns fast veralbert.
Ja.
Maximilians Intelligenzquotient
liegt bei 149+.
Das heisst,
er reizt die gängige Skala aus.
Wie lebt es sich als Hochbegabter?
Und wie leben Eltern
mit einem Wunderkind?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Mein erstes Zusammentreffen
mit Maximilian Janisch
findet anlässlich einer Konferenz
in Genf statt.
Thema: die Zukunft des Lernens.
Maximilian ist als Redner eingeladen.
... of the learning ... education.
Education system.
Wie hast du dich
für den Auftritt vorbereitet?
Alleine oder mit deinem Vater?
Zusammen.
Wir haben einen Text geschrieben.
Der entlang dem Buch geht.
Er schrieb einen Prototyp,
ich verbesserte ihn,
dann liessen wir ihn übersetzen.
Und dann haben wir
so kleine Kärtchen geschrieben.
Hast du heute frei?
Wieso konntest du herkommen?
Nach einem kleinen Kampf,
wie immer, mit der Schule -
wir haben oft mal so kleine "Aus-
fälle" - haben wir frei bekommen.
Und ja, das finde ich auch sehr
nett, denn wir müssen öfter mal
zum Fernsehen oder ähnliche Dinge,
und dann kriegen wir ab und zu frei.
Das finde ich noch angemessen.
Und "wir" sind du und dein Vater?
Genau.
Ihr seid ein "wir"?
Also, wir 3 eigentlich.
Wir 3 - mit der Mutter. Sie ist
heute leider Gottes im Office.
In seinem Referat redet Maximilian
von seiner Schulkarriere,
die er im Schnellzugstempo
absolviert hat.
Primarschule in 3 Jahren,
Mathematura mit 9 Jahren,
Förderung an der Universität Zürich.
Englisch:
Mein Weg war nicht immer einfach.
Aber ich hatte immer
Menschen um mich, die mir halfen.
Ich glaube, die Gesellschaft
hat die Verpflichtung,
alle Kinder individuell zu fördern.
Hochbegabte und Normalbegabte.
Zögern Sie nicht zu fragen!
Der 11-jährige Maximilian
besucht die 3. Klasse
des Gymnasiums Immensee.
Seine Klassenkameraden
sind 14 und 15 Jahre alt.
Jeden Mittag
holt ihn sein Vater Thomas Drisch,
der aus erster Ehe
4 weitere Kinder hat,
in der Schule ab und bringt ihn nach
Hause ins luzernische Meierskappel.
Maximilians Mutter
ist promovierte Betriebsökonomin.
Fürs gemeinsame Mittagessen
unterbricht sie jeden Tag
ihre Arbeit.
Er kam ja relativ jung, mit 9,
aufs Gymnasium.
Und ihm fehlte einfach etwas.
Es wäre ja ein Tagesgymnasium,
das so was auch anbietet,
vollumfängliche Betreuung
und auch Mittagessen.
Aber das sagte ihm gar nicht zu,
er hatte Heimweh,
und deshalb
pflegen wir das weiterhin.
Weisst du, ob es in naher Zukunft
Klassenarbeiten gibt?
Ja, morgen Geschichte,
übermorgen Geografie
und überübermorgen Biologie.
Das gibt viel zu tun,
herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Ich finde,
meine Begabung liegt darin,
dass ich Dinge schneller begreife
als viele andere.
Und meine Hauptbegabung
liegt in der Mathematik.
Dort bin ich am schnellsten und
begreife vielleicht manchmal Dinge,
die andere
nie begreifen werden.
Aber das liegt vielleicht
auch daran,
dass sie sich nicht
mit Mathematik auseinandersetzen.
Hallo und willkommen zurück
bei "Mathe mit Maximilian".
Auf einer Lernplattform
macht Maximilian heute
Gymnasiasten für die Matura fit.
Seine Hochbegabung zeichnete sich
erst nach der Einschulung ab.
Er übersprang Klasse um Klasse und
landete mit 8 Jahren am Gymnasium.
Es war Ihnen klar, dass er sich
in der Schule langweilte?
Ja, kein Ausdruck. Kein Ausdruck!
Ja, und wir hatten ja auch
sog. Hausaufgaben.
Er sass dann hier am Küchentisch
und gähnte vor sich hin.
Es hatte keinen Sinn. Also ...
In der Biografie beschreibt er, dass
er jeden Tag bis 20 zählen musste.
Dabei wusste er,
was eine Billion ist.
Und dann fingen sie an,
Zahlen zu addieren mit Überschlag,
7 plus 5 oder so.
Also, eklig ...
Ein psychisches Gefängnis.
Hat man ihn nicht zusätzlich
gefördert mit schwierigeren Aufgaben?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Im Grunde ist dieses Enrichment,
wie es heisst,
zumindest in den Schulen, in denen
Maximilian war, gar nicht möglich,
weil die Kompetenz und vielleicht
auch die Ressourcen fehlen.
Es gab dann das IF, das kennen Sie
vielleicht: integrative Förderung.
Das war der absolute Müll.
Da hätte eigentlich Maximilian die
IF-Lehrerinnen unterrichten müssen.
Das war Müll.
Die Frage des hochbegabten Kindes
und der Umgang mit diesem Kind
polarisiert zu 100 %.
Es gibt jene,
die es genau für richtig halten,
dass man
ein hochbegabtes Kind fördert.
Und es gibt die anderen, die sagen,
die Eltern seien Spinner,
die sich auf dem Rücken
des armen Kindes verwirklichten.
Es werde zum Erfolg geprügelt,
das seien die klassischen
Eiskunstlauf-Väter oder -Mütter,
die das Kind eigentlich für die
eigenen Ambitionen missbrauchen.
Aber das musste ich lernen:
Es gibt nur diese 2 Meinungen
zu diesem Thema.
Es gibt nichts anderes,
keinen Graubereich.
Und zumindest ich musste lernen, mit
dieser Herausforderung umzugehen.
Mit 9 Jahren machte Maximilian
die Mathematura mit Bestnoten,
die Matura in den anderen Fächern
steht ihm noch bevor.
Nachdem ihm die ETH
die Aufnahme verwehrt hat,
fährt er alle 2 Wochen
an die Universität Zürich,
wo ihm der renommierte italienische
Professor Camillo De Lellis
ein speziell auf ihn zugeschnittenes
Förderprogramm anbietet.
Du hast genau diese Sache von einer
Seite und von der anderen Seite.
Maximilians Begabung
ist aussergewöhnlich.
Ich habe noch nie jemanden gesehen,
der in diesem Alter
die höhere Mathematik
so gut versteht wie Maximilian.
Er ist nach meiner Erfahrung
eine ganz grosse Ausnahme.
Camillo De Lellis
war selber hochbegabt
und wurde schon mit 29 Jahren
ordentlicher Professor.
Aufgabenstellungen wie diesen
war er aber erst
mit etwa 14 Jahren gewachsen.
Im Gegensatz zu Maximilian durfte
De Lellis keine Klassen überspringen
und bewegte sich stets
unter Gleichaltrigen.
Die Tatsache,
dass er mit jemandem reden kann,
der sein Interesse
für die Mathematik teilt
und die höhere Mathematik kennt,
ist gut für ihn, denke ich.
Es wäre auch für mich gut gewesen.
Ich hätte das sehr gerne gehabt.
Maximilians Bezugspersonen
sind ausnahmslos älter als er:
sein Professor an der Uni,
seine Eltern,
seine 14- und 15-jährigen
Klassenkameraden am Gymnasium.
Stellen Sie sich vor,
er wäre jetzt in der 6. Klasse
der Primarschule Meierskappel.
Welches Interesse würde er
mit den anderen Kindern teilen?
Überhaupt keines!
Selbst wenn er auf Dinos zu sprechen
käme oder Kosmologie, egal was,
fände er keinen Ansprechpartner.
D.h., das Problem besteht,
egal ob die anderen jünger,
gleichaltrig oder älter sind.
Und es besteht weniger,
je älter sie sind.
Ein 10-Jähriger an der Uni -
Stoff für ein Buch,
dachte sich ein welscher Verlag
und bekundete Interesse
an Maximilians Biografie.
Als Ghostwriter beschreibt
der 69-jährige Thomas Drisch
den Kampf der Familie um eine
adäquate Förderung Maximilians.
Die Hauptbotschaft dieses Buches
könnte man wie folgt bezeichnen:
Die besonderen Talente,
z.B. im Sport ...
... Tanz, in der Musik
werden tatsächlich in der Schweiz
ausreichend gefördert.
Es gibt,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
23 Sportgymnasien in der Schweiz.
Die besonderen Talente
in den MINT-Fächern,
Mathematik, Informatik,
Naturwissenschaften und Technik,
haben diese Möglichkeit nicht.
Also, komm mal etwas näher!
Wie du weisst, unterziehe ich mich
gerade einer stressigen Aufgabe.
Bist du zufrieden
mit deinem Ghostwriter?
Ja, kann man sagen.
Ich bin zufrieden, ja. Vollkommen.
Erkennst du dich in diesem Buch oder
sind das die Gedanken deines Vaters?
Überhaupt nicht,
eigentlich ist es von mir.
Der Buchtitel lautet quasi:
"Ich bin doch kein Phänomen."
Aber du bist schon ein Phänomen,
nicht?
Na ja ...
Mit diesem Talent, dieser Begabung.
Es kommt darauf an,
was man als Phänomen bezeichnet.
Wir haben ja
ein Fragezeichen dahinter gesetzt.
Man kann streiten ...
... ob oder ob nicht.
Wie schätzen Sie das Phänomen,
das Phänomenale an Maximilian ein?
Ich behaupte ja,
es gibt wahrscheinlich
Tausende von Kindern
ähnlicher Begabung.
Das Phänomen, wenn man es so
bezeichnet, entsteht dadurch,
dass Maximilian
in einem Umfeld aufwächst,
wo dieser Begabung optimal
Rechnung getragen werden kann.
Wie gehts hier weiter?
Jetzt rechts
und danach noch mal links.
Noch mal links?
In den Frühlingsferien
begeben sich Vater und Sohn
auf eine Buchpromotionstour
nach Paris.
3 Auftritte bei grossen französischen
Fernseh- und Radiostationen
stehen auf dem Programm.
Wo muss ich hier fahren?
Nach links.
Ja, aber ...
Leichter gesagt als getan.
In 3 Min.
beginnt ein Live-Interview im Radio,
was Maximilian
nicht im Geringsten beunruhigt,
während ich im Fond des Wagens
doch etwas zittere.
Ich lasse dich hier raus
und komme dann gleich.
In 5 Min. oder so.
Bis gleich.
Pour?
Pour RTL.
On arrive.
Bonjour.
Eine Live-Sendung auf Französisch -
keine grosse Sache für Maximilian,
der seine Ferien
jeweils in Südfrankreich
auf dem Anwesen seiner Eltern
verbringt
und dort mit den Nachbarskindern
spielt und nur französisch spricht.
Bonjour,
c'est le père de Maximilian.
Vous pouvez lui donner le livre?
Du bist 11, Maximilian,
herzlich willkommen!
Hast du einen besten Freund,
eine Freundin?
Ja, sie heisst Mahina.
Wie alt ist sie?
Ich glaube, sie ist 14.
Habt ihr Gemeinsamkeiten?
Nein, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Aber ich verliere in der Schule
immer meine Blätter,
sie lässt mich ihre kopieren.
Merci à vous deux.
"Merci ..." Was sagen wir?
"... d'être venu"?
Wie bitte?
"D'être venu avec moi"?
"Merci", ja.
Maximilian ist gewieft
im Umgang mit Medien.
Wie ist es gelaufen, Maximilian?
Ganz gut.
Also ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Und Sie, Herr Drisch?
Ich bin auch sehr zufrieden.
Er war sehr schlagfertig,
das kann man sagen.
Du wirst immer das Gleiche gefragt.
Was nervt am meisten?
Ich weiss, dass es immer gleich ist.
Keine Frage nervt am meisten, ein-
fach die Monotonie der Fragen nervt.
Was sollen die Journalisten fragen?
Was würdest du gerne beantworten?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Aber einfach mal
andere, neue Fragen.
Zum Beispiel?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne nur die Fragen,
die mich andere schon gefragt haben.
Aber ... ja, z.B.:
Was machst du in Frankreich?
Das hat mich noch keiner gefragt.
Ich spiele gerade mit einem Freund
ein Cache-cache-trappe-trappe
und Trampolin.
Und sonst programmiere ich
manchmal etwas Kleines.
Und mache Mathe.
Der nächste Interviewtermin
steht erst morgen auf dem Programm -
Zeit für ein bisschen Shopping.
Tom, hier hats "Asterix"!
Jetzt aber los!
Den da habe ich noch nicht.
Den habe ich, den auch.
Das habe ich noch nicht.
"Asterix" liest du gerne?
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Was findest du so toll daran?
Ich finde den Text humorvoll
und die Zeichnungen schön.
Ich hätte eher gedacht,
du liest dicke Schinken, Romane.
Ne, das ist nicht mein Ding.
"Asterix" eher?
Was hat er empfohlen?
# Manuel Neuer, bester Torwart.
# Manuel Neuer, Dichter und Denker.
# Manuel Neuer, ho ho ho.
Wollen wir noch
den Eiffelturm haben?
Den was?
Den Eiffelturm.
Ah, nein.
Nein?
Nein.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir mal.
Sie haben noch 4 andere Kinder.
Ich denke aber,
diese Vaterschaft unterscheidet sich
fundamental von den anderen.
Zunächst unterscheidet sich,
ich sage mal,
der Mindset der Gesellschaft.
Was wir jetzt machen, wäre damals
als abscheuliches, elitäres Gehabe
klassifiziert worden.
Es war nicht möglich, in die Schule
zu kommen und zu sagen:
"Der Bursche langweilt sich. Darf er
nicht eine Klasse überspringen?"
Aber ich hatte auch eine Frau,
die gegen das Leistungsprinzip war.
Sie achtete mehr darauf,
dass es für die Jugendlichen
und früher für die Kinder
wirklich ein Leben
mit vielen Glücksmomenten ist.
Ich selbst bin anders.
Was heisst das?
Sie wollen ja auch
ein Leben mit vielen Glücksmomenten.
Aber ich empfinde das Glück
am meisten,
wenn man mit aller Kraft,
die man zur Verfügung hat,
zum Ergebnis gekommen ist.
Der Augenblick
der völligen Erschöpfung.
Das ist für Sie Glück?
Ja.
Denken Sie,
das ist für Maximilian auch so?
Ja, das denke ich. Ja.
Was darum auch in Paris nach
einem langen Tag nicht fehlen darf:
die tägliche Übungsstunde
"Mathe für Maximilian".
Und noch ganz kurz eine Frage:
Wenn das ein Vektor ist,
wie schreibt man dann
alle Ableitungen?
Schreibt man das dann als Matrix?
Maximilian als Ihr Pensionsalters-
projekt zu bezeichnen,
würden Sie wahrscheinlich
als unverschämt empfinden, nicht?
Also um das Missverständnis
ganz auszuräumen:
Ich habe auch weitere Projekte.
Ich habe z.B. 3 Bauprojekte
im Augenblick.
In gewisser Weise kann man
die Biografie von Maximilian
als, in diesem Fall,
gemeinsames Projekt bezeichnen.
Man geht in die Irre,
wenn man sagt -
und das habe ich ja
schon ausgeführt -
dass man sich ausschliesslich
auf das eigene Kind konzentriert.
Damit wird dem Kind
kein Gefallen getan.
Aber man kann schon sagen,
ich bin ein Projekt für dich.
Ein Riesenprojekt,
und ein Projekt, das Spass macht.
Das freut mich.
Bist du gerne ein Projekt?
Ich bin sehr gerne ein Projekt.
Ich meine, jeder braucht
ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit.
Am nächsten Morgen:
Wegen eines Streiks
beim staatlichen Fernsehsender
ist das geplante Interview
ins Wasser gefallen.
Deshalb gibt es einen Abstecher
in den Bois de Boulogne.
Das kippt!
Das macht nichts.
Ein bisschen nach links lehnen.
Das hat keinen Motor, nichts.
Das ist reines Wasser.
Das Wasser bringt es zum Fahren.
Wie würdest du die Beziehung
zu deinem Vater beschreiben?
Ja, ich würde sagen,
die ist schon ziemlich eng.
Er ist eben, wie schon gesagt,
mein Vorbild, mein Vater,
mein Förderer
und auch mein zweitbester Freund.
Und wer ist dein bester Freund?
Meine Mutter. Also, ja ...
Was magst du am liebsten
an deinem Vater?
Beide lachen.
Seinen Humor habe ich gerne.
Seine "Buddhistischkeit"
habe ich recht gerne.
Genau, ich bin ein echter Buddhist.
Und was haben Sie am liebsten
an Ihrem Sohn?
Seine Sonnigkeit.
Mein Sohn hat, ganz anders als ich,
ein unglaublich sonniges Gemüt.
Das muss er
von seiner Mutter geerbt haben.
Maximilians Schulkarriere
und seine Förderung polarisieren.
Nach den ersten Medienauftritten
vor knapp 2 Jahren
ergoss sich ein Shitstorm
über Maximilian und seine Eltern.
Einige Zuschauer werden denken:
"Lasst doch diesen Jungen
mal im Wald herumrennen
oder Fussball spielen!"
Aber das interessiert ihn nicht.
Das interessiert ihn wirklich nicht.
Wir haben ihm diese Möglichkeiten
selbstverständlich geboten.
wir haben ihn an die Fasnacht,
an Kindergeburtstage mitgenommen.
Es hat genug Kinder in der Umgebung,
der Wald beginnt hinter dem Haus.
Wir haben versucht,
alle Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen
und ihm dieses Angebot zu machen.
Aber dieses Angebot
hat er nicht angenommen,
und so muss man es akzeptieren.
Zwingen kann man ihn nicht.
Darum vor dem Schlafengehen:
Kosmologie statt Kinderkanal.
TV:  Ein schwarzes Loch
ist praktisch das Ende von allem.
Des Sterns, der Materie,
der Energie, der Schwerkraft.
Es ist der absolute Endpunkt.
Macht dir das keine Angst?
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass uns ein schwarzes Loch trifft,
ist etwa gleich Null.
Das Universum ist so riesig,
v.a. weil es 3-dimensional ist.
Wäre es 2-dimensional,
wäre die Wahrscheinlichkeit höher.
Aber es gibt so wenige
schwarze Löcher in unserer Nähe,
und dass es uns trifft und einsaugen
kann, ist so unwahrscheinlich,
dass mir das
überhaupt keine Angst macht.
Ich glaube, es ist wirklich
ein Geschenk, eine Gabe,
wenn man selber so sein darf.
Für Maximilian beurteile ich es so.
Aber auch für uns Eltern.
Es macht Freude, Diskussionen
mit ihm zu haben und das zu sehen.
Und man wird ja auch
selbst gefordert.
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass man tatenlos zusehen kann,
sondern man wird gefordert,
man muss Antworten geben, man muss
sich mit Dingen auseinandersetzen.
Und manchmal
kommt man selbst ins Nachdenken,
wofür ich dankbar bin,
was ich auch einfach schön finde.
Wie siehst du deine Zukunft?
Wie würdest du gerne leben?
Möchtest du im Ausland leben,
in der Schweiz?
Möchtest du Wissenschaftler werden,
Familie haben, Kinder?
Familie werde ich sicher haben.
Ich möchte nicht
auf mich allein gestellt sein.
Ich bin jetzt auch
in einem Dreierteam.
Aber mehr kann ich nicht sagen,
ich nehme es halt so, wie es kommt.
Keine Zukunftsvorstellungen?
Nein, noch keine.
Zukunftswünsche?
Auch keine grossen.
Ich bin so zufrieden,
wie ich gerade bin.